it's been ten years since sister
carmaker sat women Puzo teamed up with
Toyota to bring a compact model on the
market given the low profit margins and
high development costs in the a segment
says Sascha this kind of collaboration
pays off the three car makers originally
teamed up to create the Toyota AYGO in
2005 alternatively badged as the Citroen
c1 and the Peugeot 107 nine years down
the road it's time for a new edition
we're testing the Peugeot 108 which
rolled off the assembly lines at the
joint plant in Killeen in the Czech
Republic the 107 is sold 850,000 units
in total and is an important project for
Pujo around 60 percent of buyers are
women so with the updated model Kujo is
expanding the color spectrum and
offering a range of custom options akin
to what Opel did with the atom
the exterior the 108 differs
significantly from its a twin and Toyota
siblings that's a change from the 107
stickers to add dashes of color to the
interior and exterior cost 390 gyros
upwards
Sasha bemoans the fact that the stickers
will probably only last three to five
years given their price they're our
waste of money in his eyes once angling
to skate the five-door version Castle
eleven and a half thousand euros even
though it doesn't have any more space
than other models Headroom is also an
issue even with the optional sunroof
Headroom in the back is insufficient
only kids would be comfy here let's
maximize for clinic Hinda does column
the trunk space has been increased even
if it's still not superlative the trunk
can hold 196 litres of cargo and simply
by folding down the back seats that can
be expanded to 780 liters the car we
tested comes close to 15,000 euros for
that price you get all the trimmings and
a more powerful engine still the 108
maxes out of 170 kilometers an hour
a bottle Sasha points out that the one
liter 3-cylinder Toyota version only
comes eight thousand eight hundred
ninety euros although that the engine
design is nine years old
the total is it well and Puzo offer an
optional one point to pure tech engine
with 60 kilowatts unnecessary
improvement reckon suction if you
compare the engines it quickly becomes
apparent that neither is first-rate but
they are economical and that's what
counts for a city runabout but Sasha has
why someone would buy a Peugeot 108
instead of its sibling vehicles it looks
the best joke buzos product press
director but he goes on to list a number
of arguments the models have stylistic
differences and the 108 is a true Pujo
in terms of the front and the back this
is clearly a car in the Pujo designed
tradition he promises and it fits well
with the company's model family Pirjo
offers a broad palette of 108
customizing options covering everything
from the bodywork to the interior
customers get numerous possibilities for
creating their own personal 108 our
verdict
108 handling is beyond reproach the
steering is good as are the comfortable
seats although they could offer some
side support the puja 108 is available
for eight thousand eight hundred ninety
arrows for that you get an agile little
city runabout but that's all you can
expect the optional 1.2 liter motor is a
must to pep up the car a bit otherwise
it's good value for money as are its
sibling cars